good afternoon everyone it's the first
time I have to hook myself myself this
so i apologize for a little little delay
i'm philip Novotny from Czech Technical
University and in the next 30 minutes I
would like to tell you something about
my my utilization of Mathematica in
image processing and exactly in the
measuring if electron microscope
micrographs and analyzing the particles
contained so the brief outline of my
talk just a few few words about the
noble metal nanoparticles and what they
present to today's technology and what
is the are the critical parameters for
exploring their properties then I will
move to the mathematical approach to the
plasma particle analysis which will be
presented as a simple image browser made
in Mathematica made as a mathematical
notebook and later more advanced
mathematical app which will be used for
particle analysis for programmatic
particle analysis and if there will be
more time in the end I would like just
to show you how to how to turn a
mathematical notebook in something which
looks for normal user which doesn't know
mathematical like normal application
so to begin with the plasmid
nanoparticles the most most pronounced
the most pronounced example is the
colloidal gold which is known for many
many thousands of years already or many
many hundreds of years from the ancient
China these are our small small
particles tiny enough they can be
dispersed in liquid and even if they are
gold there much denser than then war
today didn't fall down they didn't
sediment because they are small enough
that the molecules of the solvent of the
water just shake them enough to be
continuously dispersed they have very
interesting optical properties apart
from what we would expect from God the
image of the while present contains
dispersion of 20 nanometer big gold
nanoparticles and the ruby color is the
actual actual effect which intrigued
humans since the ancient China that they
thought that this kind of God have some
mystical properties are mystical healing
properties which weren't confirmed today
but because the people drink it through
the wrong time we know that the
colloidal gold could be used as a as a
like utility as the agent in the living
organism to transfer under kind of
medicaments for example the interesting
things how the particles is the
emergence of plasmon resonance which is
oscillation of the localized electron
electron cloud and the metallic particle
and more importantly the shape matters
in this in this kind of things so when
you are able to prepare different
morphologies of the nanoparticles in the
solution it critically it enormously
change the optical properties of the
solution in the first or do you can see
it by just naked eye so there's there's
a possibility to connect the
characterization
the particles in the solution to their
color of course to do this you need to
have some some big amount of data of
which how the particles and which shapes
produce different what curves produce
different shape of the particles and so
you need the only thing you can do today
is take an item microscope which see the
morphology of the particles and try
somehow camp each of the particle its
size its shape and get some statistical
statistical number for each colloidal
solution with cystic really large number
of particles and this is exactly what i
do what i do in Mathematica there are
several of course there's several course
of open source and commercial packages
or soft pairs to do this none of them
does everything i would i would like to
have so this is this is the motivation
but why I why I prepare the code in a
mathematica what do you need usually is
you need to first filter the digital
images which are often noisy cause
director microscope although they are
very advanced the technology
applications of the partner particles
technology uses different kind of
substrate such as glass which can be
used in modern electron microscope which
are which are specialized in very nice
to be able to take very nice images of
the nanoparticles but on very
specialized substrates so there's still
still a big need technology need to
characterize the particle in a very
noisy images as I will show you in the
following slides so the first thing the
first thing one usually do when he
discovers this kind of problem he wants
to just to measure few particles by hand
this can be done in Mathematica very
very
easily by preparing this kind of dynamic
environment which is actually a
mathematic a notebook window we just
been stripped of the of the usual
cell-cell background and self cell
helpers on the on the side and which can
act as a simple simple image browser
with the difference that you can take
calibrated measurements inside inside
the image this kind of functionality can
be done within a single single dynamic
module so I will try to show and you
just create a crater document a new
notebook is from your code using a
single dynamic module containing all the
older functionality with with the very
neat possibility which Mathematica gives
you that the damage module can have
initialization of the of the definition
of your functions at the beginning at
the beginning of the call of the Deneb
module specified as root delayed so then
the initializations are called every
time you open the notebook again so die
this way you can actually define your
functions in in the single file and it
can have the functionality of the
application in in a way that you can
save your you can save your work as I go
just demonstrate now I will save the
notebook in it's like this image one
I'll kill the Assad the colonel
hopefully he'll work
so now I'm starting fresh with fresh
colonel and you see I have the I have
the data and on the functioning of the
definitions are working were stored
locally in the notebook so this way you
can create very very cheaply in in the
amount of coding you need to write
thanks to Mathematica localization of
variables you can create this kind of
application like notebooks which allows
you to store your work in like a
notebook like a single files which
contains both the code coding and also
your data of course you can you can then
program that you can change the
measurements and of course you can
export them which I just saw you like
like the export 2d 2d to the internal
windows memory so this can be the basic
functionality you can you can do very
quickly in Mathematica to measure
measure the particles in electron
micrographs of course the next step is
to make mathematical to measure then
them automatically and this is actually
this is actually field where there is
whether the norm of the the common
software for particle resolve the
resolving of the particles have some
problems with different shapes which is
actually for the colloidal particles of
made of noble metals is the critical
parameter to be able to to determine the
shape of the particle and more
parameters usually you're and if and
with measuring the parameter the
diameter of the equivalence feel radius
of them you're measured particle which
is actually not
not good parameter from this kind of
experimental materials so the question
is can I just make Mathematica to do
this for example to be able to measure
rod like particles to be able to resolve
the aggregates automatically and what I
want to show you that of course you can
you can do anything in Mathematica it
just takes some of time I will try to
run it in a version 10 it will be little
surprised if it work so this is not yet
ready in the form of the of the
application notebook this is just normal
Nobuko parents and in the end the
application GUI the graphic user
interface is contained within one
manipulate and tab view the the
processing work flow of this kind of
electron microscopy images can be
following first you need to further the
image denies the image to be able to
make either either mineralisation or
edge detection of your particles to be
able to reserve the the boundaries of
the particles and resolve the in
individual particles from from the
aggregates then you need to select the
morphological properties you want to
compute for each of the particles and
most important things which i think is
very important and not it's very
problematic normal softwares is to be
able to have the possibility to
post-process the automatic automated
result to be able to hand pick selected
aggregates which were for example which
weren't for example found by the barrier
code so you try to reproduce that result
in in the mathematica application
whether i load the load some image
makers
big image you can see in mathematica you
can do several several times of custom
control which this is just modified go
gautsche control we're on the background
of gouge is is used to produce the
histogram of the image levels so this is
these are the easy ones and flowing you
can prepare this kind of working
environment mathematica where you just
select the portion of the image where
you want to tune your filters for the
filtering of the image and then I think
it's very very handy to use the
mathematical dynamic dynamic
functionality to be able to tune the
photos to your tour needs because
otherwise we would spend sometimes
iterating iterating the D commands and
this is not usually the the quickest way
when you're working with new sample so
this way I can select this is D this is
the original image and for example first
I'd like some noise filtering filters
try to tune it you can see the dynamic
response in the in the selected window
sub sub image you can of course compare
it it's easy in mathematica to do the
comparison of the of the two tumor
images overlaid on top of themselves and
just to quicken in the app of course I
have I have this kind of images already
found on the best approach but then I
will apply some some kind of sharpening
and in the end through the edge detect
function I would find the borders of the
of the detected particles and fill them
for them to get the final final
minimized image which could be of again
checked against the original if it if it
works
what is good functionality which can be
implemented by mathematical very quickly
is that of course when you layer more of
those filters on top of on top of them
of each other the computation will slow
down because with every every movement
of the dynamic slider you recompute hold
the whole image you can implement this
kind of freezing freezing of the first
layers of your selective filters so they
are computed and free frozen you can
change them but you can play with the
last with the last with the last filter
and have the computation more real-time
anyway when you are satisfied you just
create the binary for the whole image
and move to the next step which will be
the selection of the morphological
properties you need to compute so there
is just for the for checking the final
image which is highlighted by the binary
image you can see the particle size nice
nicely resolved here is the selection of
the morphological properties and you can
measure the components for each
particles which is just the
visualization of component measurement
functionality in Mathematica if there's
something around 900 of particles so it
takes takes a while I've entered some
number of properties we can move to the
what is in my opinion the most important
part because there you can get the
immediate feedback on the selection of
your parameters and you can see all the
parameters you selected to be computed
for each particle in a histogram view
where you can see for some example some
parameters like the bounding this
coverage you can see
that there is some division some
multiple sets in your particle ensemble
which of course corresponds to the
different shape in the images so this is
the way how you can programmatically
then find the parameters how to how to
differentiate the shapes of the
particles you can you can try to do nain
you should see you see dynamically
changing the the enzyme blows which are
selected so I will try to select the
spherical ones and of course you can
also you can also implement the
functionality to handpick some of the
Parkers you would you couldn't find very
quickly for example this is some kind of
aggregate I can click on it so it's
omitted from the from the final analysis
and also very very handy is to visualize
the distribution of the particles in
this kind of two dimensional parameter
plot for example I can select this kind
of this kind of access which is which is
good information in information with the
connection with the images you can see
you can now click even in the 2d plot on
the point you want to omit you can see
them where they are located in the image
so in the end is really speeds up the
finding of the right conditions for the
exact parameters of your measurements of
the of the exact color sampler which of
course differs on both the method of the
preparation of the sample for the
microscope and then the methods the
methods further for the analysis then
you can move it's then really easy in
Mathematica to prepare for examples this
kind of report of D of the image so you
can see down these spreads of the
parameters the yields of of the rods of
the spheres and you can of course joy
moore park more images together for this
kind of analysis so this is the main
functionality i'm very happy i can do
this with Mathematica reasonably quickly
thanks to its very very neat dynamic
dynamic controls do and a lot of the
things you have very fast thanks to the
manipulate construct so I think this is
this is this is for me it is very nice
utilization of Mathematica mathematical
possibilities now we have still some
minutes to I think five minutes or
something like that one minute 55 so
there's still the part where we can
build a small I can exactly show you how
I prepare the application notebook or of
course first I would like to know if you
have any questions for this kind of
particle utilization of Mathematica